fur let's talk about perfor if you could
would you want a guy that made more
money than you all things okay okay okay
okay wait wait wait okay if you could
would you prefer a man that's stronger
than you yes or no okay okay if you
could would you prefer a man that's
smarter than you maybe can fix things
around the house yes no okay so that's
what I'm saying there are other things
that men bring
that you get just from having a man
around outside of money like I love that
I can call my like we all know as women
and maybe maybe you guys are better than
me my my air pressure light is always on
my oil has never changed my my smoke
alarm battery will always be beeping and
am I it's like when the men come around
and they're like how are you living like
this like my dad will like run around
you're smiling I bet you can think of a
time where someone's done this right and
they run around and they'll just fix
everything and just be like why are you
doing this and it's just something like
comforting like I I feel better like if
I'm stressed or whatever I just love
talking to my dad and my brothers like
there's just something about talking to
like masculine men where it's like you
just feel better I'm gonna it's great
for a man to be masculine of course but
what I'm saying is I value more in a man
I want a partner I like I don't care
about all this fixed and light bulb we
can get someone to do that I need
someone that cares about me after I've
had a long day off I would be really
curious I want to talk to you and
such a long day I want you to just
listen to me when women talk to men
they're like okay you're telling me all
this stuff what's the solution they want
to know how are you going to fix
whatever it is you're telling me that
was the solution well at least you've
been a companion no no they're they want
you they they really don't care about
the venting is mental they're like okay
you've told me all this stuff but you're
not gonna fix it don't come back to me
and say the same stuff that you told me
the day before fix it and move on that's
that's how men's come up with a solution
together
that's how it's work and maybe because I
can't watch the question questions
that's why I know that many times your
last relationship how long was it uh
probably like oh I don't like to get
personal I like nearly uh okay okay I
was just gonna say longer than six
months yeah yeah okay okay did you end
it or did he I ended it okay so so this
is just from the men's point of view
okay women will say I want an
emotionally available man and this isn't
just you remember I see you in different
bodies every day and and it's like so
then like what they'll do is they'll
realize that the same man they said were
emotionally available I dated him we
also ended it with yes and and so and
I've asked this question a lot it's very
rare it was the other way around
typically when I ask this like oh he was
emotionally available I got the things I
wanted it's like well why did it and
usually she ended it but I'm not gonna
because you don't you don't have to you
don't have to say why you don't have to
say one I won't go into it I respect all
my exes I think they were amazing I've
dated very good men I respect them they
were Kings right but the reason I
wouldn't even say like the full reason
but in terms of just the reason a lot of
women leave a relationship is because
they didn't have other things that keep
them excited so things like being
ambitious for example or a man that is
confident in himself a man that wants
more for himself in life those are the
stuff that sometimes if it's missing or
maybe a man that doesn't take care of
himself like yeah you could be
emotionally available to me I love that
and that's the reason I stayed with you
but I need you to also work on yourself
did you know you know be a better man
and if you don't want that for yourself
it's a bit harder if you're not did you
not ask them these questions or know
this stuff before you got into a
relationship I'm not going to talk about
my relationship
I just want to like just simple yes and
I don't want to like go deep into it
where you like did you have those I
think you never really know someone
until you're in a relationship I think
it takes a lot of time to know the type
of person it is because when you get
into a relationship you see the good
stuff because things I've always
prioritized is I want a great family
like I do not want to be a single mother
so I will always pick um I don't care
about how much money you I don't care
about protector I need a man that's
going to be a good father to my children
and usually those are men that are good
communicating so so this is this is I'm
just gonna tell you what remember what
you said this is contradicting what you
said because if you don't care about
money then you don't care if he's
ambitious
and that's if you don't remember earlier
you were talking about how you didn't
care so much about money you care more
about emotionally and I don't care about
him paying for me because but I'm saying
then so so if you're ambitious if you're
ambitious
okay okay okay but I know so that
translates into money in the future
right so okay okay so this is where
right right okay but this is why men
don't really trust what women say
because you're saying oh I don't care
about the money but when you when you're
presented with a man who's like eh I'm
good with the money I have and I'm not
that ambitious you're like no I can't
stay for this if it came across that I
said I don't care about men that like as
money I I care about a man that's
ambitious right you don't have to have
so you would not but you need to be hard
working I'm wanting money when I say I
don't care about money it means a little
more I'm not gonna go for a man purely
because of money because it's a hard
work and I'm ambitious so I'm not gonna
put that on you to pay for my lifestyle
because I want to prioritize other
characteristics in a man but to say that
I don't care about money yes I do I do
because I I Love Money myself I gotta
make money so my man's gonna make money
but I'm just saying this is why a man
like don't believe what women say
because we constantly contradict
ourselves and it's like the other
question I'm just telling you how the
men would hear what you said if you said
oh they're great guys
um but they were bums they would either
hear that you you date losers or they
would hear that you're not loyal because
you leave good men this is just I'm
telling you how they would take it
[Music]
I think like my biggest problem is like
I first of all I hear all of you like I
totally agree with what a lot of you
guys are saying I think my biggest
problem is that I do want someone that I
can talk about my day with and what you
said is a fact men are problem solvers
they don't want to hear you gripe they
just want to fix it and that's where
I'm going through this like trying to
figure out what exactly I'm wanting or
needing but like I want someone that can
listen to that yeah and I don't know if
I'm asking for a [ __ ] unicorn yeah
but I want to be able to I want to be
able to talk about what happened at the
nail salon I do want to have that
friendship I don't need you every single
time I talk about something to try to
fix it right of course we want someone
who can who has the potential to fix a
light bulb whatever great but I think
that was the big that's been the biggest
Factor I've been missing in my
relationships is like a friend and so
that's where I don't know how it's
supposed to go how it's going to end
what it's supposed to be how how am I
supposed to adjust my expectations what
am I am I asking for something that's
unrealistic I have a question
could you think
of a friend that you have right now that
you could potentially see yourself with
I'm gonna be very honest with you I do
not really buy into the whole male
friend thing that's just a
probably a bit of a jaded belief I can
probably I can be aware enough to say
that
um
I don't know I I honestly was sexually
assaulted by my best friend before my
30th birthday actually so I have a
little bit of a like I'm I don't want to
close that part of my heart off but I
just
any doubt I had about it it felt like it
was confirmed a little bit I'm like if
if you if I'm drunk and you're given the
chance you're gonna finger me in my
sleep and that's like literally what
happened to me so so yeah so it's like I
just I don't know if I buy into that
just yet but never say never but you
know what can I just say something that
is quite interesting yeah
I grew up having mostly guy friends
because I was a tomboy I played sports
did everything I used to be with boys
that is why even though I have a more
feminine image now what's inside is
quite different and one thing that I
understand very well and one thing that
they told me and one thing that I've
picked up along the years
what happened in the nail salon a lot of
the time is petty and I'm not trying to
say this because I'm trying to be Richie
because I know and I have girlfriends
and when they come to me to talk about
what happened in the nail salon I'm like
wow how is this going to add to my life
this is mental clutter do you know that
I have this to do tomorrow I have this
to do tomorrow I have big things to
worry about you're trying to chew my ear
off over something that is so petty that
if you took two seconds to think within
yourself and reflect you'll be able to
let it go straight away and then instead
of spending 5-10 minutes talking about
something pointless we could be talking
about something that is more productive
and sometimes more substantial and I
think that a lot of the time what we
girls get get you know and I say wiggles
just so that I don't single myself out
but what girls tend to do a lot of the
time is waste time talking about
nonsense that doesn't mean anything I
don't care about what happened to the
nail salon what's that doing to advance
my life you can say you know what these
people in the nail salon was so damn
rude you know babe I need to go to the
next one I need to go somewhere else
actually do you know what next time what
do you reckon I should say I that's a
great way to get him involved but even
still there's no point I think the the
point is like relationships work better
if as women we can unload our problem
and talk to other women about our
problems and go to our men about like
problems we want to solve it's not to
say you can never talk to like of course
my mom would [ __ ] to my dad about Tracy
[ __ ] you Tracy
but but it's it's just saying like in
general men don't want to hear about it
and it's like if you're selling we're
the cars right and I know women aren't
cars but like we're the cars you have to
know your buyer and if your buyer
doesn't like listening to our problems
maybe we could try to tell tell them
about them less unless we want them
fixed yeah and don't put and don't put
like a lot of the emotional because this
is the thing girls sometimes can be
really Petty and it's like I understand
because I'm always on the guy's side
with this because I don't have time for
that I also say to some of my girls like
listen you're really stressing me out
because we've gone over the same problem
I've given you the same solution we're
still talking about it those things are
not needed you can have some you can be
your best a best friend with your with
your man so easy you can talk about a
million different things where you
expand each other's minds I think that
sometimes what goes wrong is that we
think our friend has to be somebody that
is burdened with our mental clutter
that's what it is because I've I have
amazing conversations with men and even
in previous relationships I've always
been able to sustain a conversation why
because I don't talk about things that I
perceive to be just like okay like here
we go just talking for the sake of it
obviously if the ghost is Juicy then
yeah and you gotta tell them you know
what I'm saying make it interesting make
it a package make it be something where
they can be involved in whereas a lot of
the time we're just like and this
happened and this happened we just want
to tell a story and not actually even
have the input from someone else and
that's really and I I definitely agree
with that for sure without a doubt I
think that's where when we were talking
about the concert stuff right like if I
if I'm telling you don't go I have a
feeling whatever the reason don't go but
we're saying that we want to have
genuine good solid friendships with
women so again so taking some of that
responsibility off of our man confiding
in women that we know would would maybe
care about the nail salon stuff but then
it's like
I don't know I guess for me it's like so
then if my friend wants to go out to a
concert I have to kind of like consider
actually consider not going but the
emotional part that I don't get from you
I get from her so I still have to have
in my mind autonomy like I should still
be able to
challenge
going to the concert because this
relationship helps our relationship stay
afloat as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible